Here we are in storyboard and to address
the first two questions in the quiz,
we want to double check that our
actions and outlets are all connected.
First let's check
the roll the dice button.
So, we'll look at the pop-up menu here,
and we can see roll the dice down here,
the roll the dice action, but
it's not connected to anything.
So, that's one connection
that's missing.
Let's go ahead and fix that.
And we also need to check the action for
the OK button.
So, that looks fine, that's hooked up.
And there's two outlets we need
to check, the two outlets for
the dice image views.
So, let's look at our
Dice View Controller.
Here, the first die outlet is set,
you can see it highlights there, but
the second die outlet is not set,
so let's go ahead and fix that.
To see where the images for
these dice are stored,
we need to open up
the project navigator.
Here, if you click on this
folder images.xcassets,
you'll see all the dice images here.
And next we're going to go into
the RollViewController.swift file and
go ahead and
close our project navigator.
And then if you look in the Roll the
Dice method, you can see that the first
value, the dice value, is coming from
calling this function randomDiceValue.
And then if you go into the function
randomDiceValue, you can see that
the method arc4Random is what's
actually generating the random numbers.
Now, if we go into the Dice
view controller file,
we can see how these random numbers
are matched up with images.
Here in this line, a view will appear.
You can see where
the image names come from.
Remember that the Dice images
have the names D1, D2, D3, etc.
Which means that the strings for
the image names can be built
up from the dice values.
Let's take another look
at these dice values.
Why do they have question
marks at the end?
We declare these properties
with optional types
because we expect them to be nil until
the rollTheDice method is called.
Remember from the first Swift
session that it's okay for
optional types to be nil.
The question mark specifies
a wrapped optional, and you can see
that the dice values are conditionally
unwrapped here in viewWillAppear.
This if let construction unwraps the
first value optional by assigning it to
a new variable under the condition
that first value is not nil.